Jonah Hill babysitting wouldn't be my
first choice or my last less than last
yeah
[Music]
the sitter stars Jonah Hill who's now
gonna babysit and go on adventures in
babysitting there's a whole convoluted
twisty turny kind of plot that involves
you know drugs and fighting and all that
good happy [ __ ] that happens when you
get babysat when you're babysitting it
happens I when I saw the trailer for
this movie I was like yeah that doesn't
look good
I just didn't was the movie funny yeah
there were undeniably some funny parts I
was laughing in parts and I was like
that is just good dialogue there old
black guy at that one club but the
characters in this movie dude there's
something off about him all right take
Jonah Hill the first thing you see is
going down on this chick that's the
first thing that happens in this movie
right there I was like [ __ ] and the
girl was like oh wow my friend was right
nice guys really are the best at going
down on chicks and then he's like uh I'm
you know like timid nice guy and you
know funny nerds because you know I'm a
nerd in this movie Whedon that we've now
established that I am an awkward nerd
he's a really nice guy and he gets home
and he's a total douchebag
sits on the couches watches TV makes his
mom answer the phone he's just a total
[ __ ] I was like all right that's a
total 180 but you know all right we now
don't know who Jonah Hill is supposed to
be is he likeable and relatable or is he
a total douchebag who's gonna grow
throughout this adventure in babysitting
it's like someone wrote two different
characters who are gonna be friends in
this movie they were like oh we can't
have two main characters let's just you
know cut their dialogue in half and just
crunch it together into one character
not blend the character to a happy
medium note no the same dialogue from
two different characters like he has
multiple personality he's a flip-flop II
kind of guy you know like that and
there's a saw the guy in the movie he's
like someone's ex-boyfriend it's a
really insignificant part but it kind of
goes on what I'm saying where the
characters weren't consistent in this
movie
the guy's like oh hey you know like hey
sorry we didn't work out but I truly do
pray for you you're like all right he's
the bible thumpers you know found god
he's gonna be that kind of nice guy then
Jonah Hill is like all right hey there's
been a misunderstanding here you know
she's pissed at you you know I'm sorry
about that the guy looks at me he's like
what are you gonna do about it Punk and
he pushes him and I'm like whoa again
with the flip-flop it kind of okay no
one knows how they're gonna be in this
movie I I get that now in fact the
characters in this movie that were
actually consistent were the kids not
all of them were likable but they were
consistent and I will give them that all
right for one you got the adopted kid
from like Mexico so he's not actually
from Mexico he's from like Cuba I don't
know where he's right he's adopted
south-of-the-border kind of adopted you
know if I throw out a country people
gonna be like oh actually he's from I
don't know where he's right he's adopted
and he's a total [ __ ] I mean like
pisses on the floor like knocks over
vases it just feeds a douchebag I don't
like that kid I didn't like him I know
it's why he's one of those characters
were you like I was gonna grow
throughout the movie you know and you'll
like him at the end I don't care I hated
him for about an hour and 15 minutes so
the other ones this little girl this
creepy little girl who walks around like
she's some e true Hollywood story
outcast or something puts all this
makeup on her face and she says things
like that's the really hot name they're
really hot she's like four or five she's
like five years old which maybe that's a
good thing in this movie for nothing
else this movie will keep pedophiles off
the streets even if only for two hours
at a time the coolest kids actually the
one with the anxiety problems or anxiety
problems but yeah he was the most
likable one little neurotic yeah but
you'd is still the most likable one
because he didn't knock [ __ ] over on the
ground like a little [ __ ] best
character in the movie was Sam Rockwell
every time he was on screen for you know
the three times he was on screen he was
the best he was like some sort of drug
lord guy and you don't know whether or
not you want to hug him when he's like
hug me I'm glad I probably would he
seems like he'd be a fun guy before he
tries to kill you but before that you
know awesome I don't know why I made him
sound Colombian Oleg hug me I don't know
I that was like Russian I got nothing
for it I see this pattern now instead of
remaking movies studios are remaking
movies without calling them remakes you
know it's like they were like oh we want
to remake planes trains and automobiles
but we can't remake planes trains and
automobiles it's a John Hughes classic
so we'll take the basic concept make
some sort of hip edgy up-to-date version
of the movie and call it do days same
thing here they wanted to remake
adventures in babysitting but they can't
call it adventures in babysitting so
they're just gonna take the basic
concept remake it make it some sort of
hip up-to-date edgy version of the movie
it's the same thing and I kind of see
this movie how I saw do daytime like
it's just not as good a movie as the 80s
movie that came before it
so flip-floppy characters a plot that
was kind of all over the place some fun
laughs for sure and three kids one was
creepy one was cold and one was an
[ __ ]
is it [ __ ] no but I will say it's a
funny time and will probably be a better
time if you're drunk
yeah no parties kids an [ __ ] so there
it is so what's your favorite movie
where people go out
on the town and just shenanigans and
craziness happens doesn't have to be a
babysitting scenario just whatever
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]